so Hebrews 11:13 let me explain what
this means god having spoken long ago to
the fathers and the prophets many
portion of many ways now saying in the
Old Testament God spoke to the
Israelites through the prophets he sent
but these prophets receive Revelation in
various ways either in dreams or visions
and at times God would
send the angel of the Lord who is Jesus
to communicate to them and through them
and or the Holy Spirit that's what it
means in many
ways right dreams Visions the angel of
the Lord would come who is Jesus in his
fre existence the Holy Spirit would come
right or both the angel with the holy
spirit so these are the various ways
that God would speak to the Israelites
sending the prophets whom God would
communicate through dreams and Visions
either seeing God in a dream or the
angel of the Lord who is Jesus right and
having the Holy Spirit communicate to
them and through them these are the
various ways
right so now let me show you those
various ways ready the various ways that
God SP spoke to them okay watch here
speaking about Moses
okay speaking about Moses right here
now show you just some of the way ways
look what he says here learn what this
means okay we're going in
depth and when a prophet would speak he
would say thus saith
yahwah thus says
yahwah thus saith the Lord keep that in
mind numbers 1258 then Yahweh came down
in a p of cloud and stood at the doorway
of the tent and he called Aaron Miriam
and then both came forward and he said
hear now my words there's a prophet
among you I Yahweh shall make myself
known to him in a vision I shall speak
with him in a dream now notice in a
dream or a vision a vision is usually
when you're awake and then Heaven opens
and you see Heaven A Dream is when
you're usually
asleep right okay keep in
mind you caught it here
I will either speak to them in a dream
or a vision but with Moses I did
something unique God entered into the
world in a visible form and Israel saw a
visible pillar of cloud by day and a
pillar of Flow by night and they heard
an aut voice speaking from the cloud and
Moses entered the cloud he did this for
Moses but if you read the rest of the
Old
Testament other
prophets would have God speaking them to
them in a dream and vision there is one
other time where we are told one other
time we are where we are told that God
again appeared visibly in a p of cloud
when Solomon dedicated the temple if you
read First Kings chapter 8:
10-13 write this down we're not going to
go there first Kings chapter 8 verse 10-
13 specifically verses 10 to 11 and then
you go to the parallel 2 Chronicles
chapter 6 veres 1- 2 chapter 7 veres 13
2 Chronicles chapter 6 verse 1-2 chapter
7 vers 1-3 it says when Solomon
dedicated Temple they saw the pillar of
cloud appear like it did at the time of
Moses
but elsewhere in the Old Testament the
prophets we either have dreams or
visions of God or of
angels you want me
there yes I can
here you with me
there everyone got
that but with Moses he appeared in a
pillar of cloud by day Pillar of Fire by
night and the whole nation of Israel and
the Egyptians saw it even the Egyptians
saw the pillar of cloud Pillar of Fire
read Exodus chapters 13 and
14 and they saw the cloud come on a
mount and they heard the voice audibly
but then Moses entered the cloud and was
there face to face not so with my
servant Moses he is Faith in all my
household with him I speak mouth to
mouth indeed clearly not in riddles and
he beholds the form of Yahweh why then
were you not afraid to speak against my
servant against Moses you
see so God would speak through the
Israelites via the prophets but how did
God speak to the prophets in dreams and
visions and in those dreams and Visions
they either see God on the throne the
host of heaven or the angel of God
appeared to them Jesus and or the Holy
Spirit okay learn this for example David
is aware that it's the spirit of
God that was speaking to him and telling
him what to say and what to write here 2
Samuel 23:1 and3 now these are the last
words of David David the son of Jesse
declares and by the way if you want to
know where prophets would have visions
where they're seeing Heaven open while
they're on Earth they're not in heaven
they're on Earth but they're seeing
Heaven open and they see God appearing
in a visible shape Seated on a visible
throne and seeing the Heavenly Host
visibly to his right and left Isaiah 6
veres 1 and 5 Isaiah sees the Lord on
the throne and the seraphim First Kings
22: 19- 23 you can read all the way to
28 First Kings chapter 22 verses 19- 23
and the parallel 2 Chronicles 18 vers
18- 22 you can read all the way to 27 2
Chronicles 18 ver 18-22 Micaiah sees
heaven open sees Yahweh on the throne
appearing in a visible form on a visible
Throne a visible shape and the host
standing to his right and left right
there okay
focus David the son of Jesse declares
the man who was raised on high declares
the anointed of the god of Jacob and the
sweet psalmist of Israel the spirit of
Yahweh spoke by me see this is one of
the ways that God spoke through the
prophets to Israel by the spirit of God
coming to David telling David what to
say and what to right and his word was
on my tongue the god of Israel said the
rock of Israel spoke to me he rules over
men as a righteous one who rules in the
fear of God now during this
period when a prophet would speak he
would say in the name of yahwah thus
says yahwah by the name of
yaha right let me show you what I mean
okay but in the time of
Christ things change after the
Incarnation things
change things change after Christ became
flesh died rose again and ascended
physically bodily into heaven but now
first let me show you Deuteronomy 1818
22 I'll raise up a prophet from among
their brothers like you and I'll put my
words in his mouth Deuteronomy 18822 he
shall speak to them all that I command
you and it will be that whoever will not
listen to my words which he shall speak
in my
name in the name of yah yahwah everyone
pronounce the name I myself required of
of him but the prophet who speaks a word
presumptuously in my name which I've
have not commanded him to speak or which
he speaks in the name of other gods that
Prophet shall die notice a true Prophet
can only prophesy in the name of Yahweh
in other words saying thus saith Yahweh
yahwah yaho Jehovah I know how to
pronounce the name it's got to be in his
name and it's got to be the words that
Yahweh told him to speak and not things
he makes up and
lies saying that Yahweh told him to say
x when he didn't and it cannot be in the
name of another God name of Allah or
Vishnu
now you may say in your
heart you may say in your
heart how will we know the word which
Yahweh has not spoken how we gonna know
if this guy's lying and Yahweh didn't
say it one way to know one there's a
criteria there's one
Criterion one way is when a prophet
speaks in the name of
Yahweh if the thing does not come about
or come true that is the thing which
Yahweh has not spoken the prophet has
spoken it presumptuously you shall not
be afraid of
him that's how you
know okay now what has changed well
here's what's
changed okay what has
changed right here you
ready in the past God would speak to
Israel through the prophets and the
prophets would receive Revelation
through various ways Jam and visions and
or visions and either they see God or
the angel of the Lord who is Jesus or
the spirit or they see
Angels
right but in these last days he speaks
to us in his son now it's
different one of the ways that the
father spoke to the prophets notice here
God is the father because it says he now
speaks to us in a
son one of the ways that God the father
would reveal his will to Israel through
the prophetes he would send Jesus in his
prehuman existence and or the Holy
Spirit now what has changed
though in these last days note two
things number one now it is by the
son by the agency of the son that God
makes his well known I'm going to
explain what that means but
notice when the sun became
that started the last days okay here's
where Christians need to learn their
theology there's something that
theologians call already not
yet it's called Already not yet meaning
the last day is not one day the last day
is actually a series of events that
transpire over a period of time this is
why sometimes it's called last day other
times it's called last
days so Envision the end as a series of
events that will transpire over a period
of time and the beginning of those last
days starts with the
Incarnation when Christ became flesh
that started the last days so the last
days is a series of events that
transpire over a period of
time the beginning of which starts with
the Incarnation that begins the last day
the last
days starts with the Incarnation and
will continue until the end of the age
when Christ descends physically and
bodily so you need to stop thinking of
the last day as One Moment In Time start
thinking of
a series of events a series of days
called the last days that began with the
Incarnation everyone got
it so this is why it's called Already
not yet the last day already began but
it hasn't been completed yet because the
last day is a series of days a series of
events that transpire over time
this is why Hebrews can say the last
days already began when Jesus showed
up I didn't say it the apple of his eye
it's right there and these last days
what last days the days in which Jesus
showed up in the
flesh you get it now
you're thinking the last day hasn't come
no it already
began the series of events called The
Last Days began with the coming of
Christ in the
flesh and it's been continuing 2,000
years
later okay I can't move on if you're not
getting it so I repeat that myself more
than once
okay sink in what does it mean that now
he speaks by a
son in other words now that Christ has
come in the flesh prophesying is done in
his name by his authority so in the Old
Testament you had thus saith Yahweh now
it's thus saith the Lord Jesus in the
name of Jesus Christ
by the authority of Jesus Christ thus
saith the Lord Jesus why do you think in
the New Testament all throughout the New
Testament especially book of Acts they
are proclaiming they are baptizing
they're doing miracles in the name of
Jesus
Christ you with me
there in the name of Jesus Christ
but you know what that means right it
means Jesus Christ has now taken the
name the place of Yahweh the name Jesus
Christ is now synonymous with the name
of
Yahweh what the name Yahweh was for the
Old Testament the name Jesus Christ is
now right for the New Testament in other
words to say thus saith the Lord Jesus
Christ has become the equivalent
of the Old Testament expression thus
saith Yahweh because Jesus Christ is
Jehovah in the flesh